hi everyone uh we are starting the
session in few minutes
so meanwhile uh please get settled in
and uh we already have our speaker here
with us partly uh so we'll start the
session in just few minutes thank you
for joining
hi everyone uh so we'll be starting the
session now uh I can see more folks are
joining in so would love to know where
are you joining from so I will just
share it here so I am Rasha Khan I'm
your host uh for today's webinar and uh
I would love to know where are you
joining from I am joining from Bangalore
India
and today we have a very interesting
session uh so it's a free AML master
class and we will be talking about how
you can build your own Spotify like
recommendation engine and also as a
bonus we have a Purdue program preview
included as well so I can see there are
so many questions already coming in the
Q a box that's great even before
starting the session uh but uh yes I can
see the introductions coming in on chat
so welcome everyone
just in few minutes we already have a
speaker here with us so that's great uh
so yeah
uh meanwhile just to give you uh really
good tip before we start so you can
always put down your questions on the Q
a box uh so we'll be having a special
session for the Q a box where if you
have any queries related to AIML uh we
will take up those questions and also
relate to the Purdue program as well in
eim
awesome I can see the introduction still
coming in so I'll just uh
you'll find one as well on chat okay
just in case you've missed if you've
just joined right now so my name is
and I am joining from India
welcome
hello I can see Rakesh has joined from
Hyderabad I can see deepshika from
Bangalore I can see Rina from
Maharashtra India I can see uh yashwin
from Dubai
okay welcome everyone
I think before we start uh so maybe
let's get to know each other a little
better so uh maybe let's
get to know like how much years of
experience do you currently have while
you're giving an introduction in the
chat here so I would love to do you can
see a quick poll on your screen and uh
very easy for quick options here if
you're currently studying you can choose
that one if you have zero to three years
of experience you can choose that one uh
and if you have three to five years of
experience you can choose a third one if
you have more than five years of
experience you can choose the fourth one
so tell me how many years of experience
do you have
before we start
and also keep the introductions coming
in if you've already voted for the
October here
okay and we already have our speaker
here with us who will be taking us
through basically how you can build your
own Spotify like recommendation engine
uh and also we have a bonus program
preview here of produce AIML uh PG so I
can see folks are asking questions on
the chat so just to let you know uh you
can put down your questions on the Q a
box uh so yeah please do that please put
down your questions in the Q a box uh so
when we will be taking taking the
questions during the session and also we
have a special duration just for the Q a
towards the end as well so in case uh if
you have any questions we don't miss out
on that so we would like to help you in
any way possible and we are speaker here
with us sort of partner we'll be
answering your questions anything will
lead to the AI email uh career graph
you're looking for uh and also the audio
program which we have of a Purdue
University AML uh in bgb so uh
so yeah please put down your questions
in the Q a box
not the chat here folks are opening on
the chat I'm so sorry we might miss it
uh so please go and put on your
questions in the Q a box
okay I can see the polls are still
moving most of the folks have already
voted uh on the poll here basically how
much experience do you have uh so for a
few folks who have not voted I'll be
closing the poll in 10 seconds so please
do quickly go and what we would love to
know how much experience do you have and
get to know you better
okay uh okay I can see few folks are
still voting in
foreign
foreign folks so sorry uh there was a
little power cut here on our end uh so I
can see that most of the folks have
already voted for the answer
let me just uh quickly end the poll here
let me just quickly share my screen as
well
I hope I'm audible to you folks
awesome awesome I'm sharing my screen
okay okay okay we are back I hope the
screen is visible to your folks
okay okay awesome uh so we have already
gotten the uh basically votes for how
many years of experience do you have uh
So currently I can see most of the folks
are currently studying and uh I can see
the folks have seated reviews of
experience and a few of them have the
three to five ways of experience and few
of them are more than five years of
experience so now moving on to the
uh agenda part so basically you'll be
getting to know more about you uh and
basically how we can help you out better
in terms of AIML career path and also
through this cardio program as well uh
we'll be talking about uh how you can
build your Spotify recommendation engine
we'll be giving a live demo of that and
we'll be getting a product program
introduction on pgp AML by purview and
also basically how this program prepares
you uh we'll be talking about learner
outcomes enrollment steps and the Q a as
well uh so there'll be a special
duration with the Q a part so folks who
are putting on questions in the Q a box
uh please uh go and do that uh so I'll
try to take it during the session but we
will have a special duration for that so
now moving on uh to our speaker here we
would like to welcome sir partner who
will be taking us through uh the live
project demo so Sarah would you like to
give us your introduction
so thank you Russia for inviting me to
this talk and master class and thank you
everyone for coming here and I hope we I
can add some value to your pursuit in
data science and animal career and maybe
you have some more clarity when you
leave this webinar
so just a little bit about myself I have
six years of experience in data enabled
products where I've worked as an
engineer I've worked as an you know like
team lead and product managers across
the companies in in the lastly six years
and where I have built various types of
recommender systems in starting from you
know like just recommending different
dishes in uh basically when you're
ordering food from a restaurant
to matching candidates to the right job
and similar apart from it I've built
various small AI ml tools for retail
organizations in India such as like
basically menu creation which is
automated by AI where we can you can
just describe the dish and we will
create the image and description of it
from these tools so this is all about me
and I hope
uh if you have any questions if you want
to know more feel free to ask
thank you so much for a great
introduction uh now moving on uh to the
title part so uh we'll be talking about
simply learn and it's cardio program
more but just to let you know this
program is powered by simply learn
world's number one bootcamp uh we are
very proud that we have trained over 5
million professionals over the last uh
you know 13 years and we have been in
this digital skills space for over 13
years and we are very proud that we are
transforming lives or improving people
be additional skills so welcome everyone
once again now I will be starting the
live project demo uh we are going to
talk about how you can build a Spotify
recommendation engine so uh now uh
basically let's talk about what exactly
is Spotify can you tell us Sarah
yeah uh I before we begin I would just
want like everybody to input their
you know like experience with Spotify
have you used it before how do you like
it and
while I explain uh what is Spotify and
where does this whole recommendation
thing comes into picture
so when we talk about certify according
to Spotify their mission is to unlock
the potential of human creativity and
they do it by giving millions of
creative artists an opportunity to live
off their art so that they can keep
making art and secondly again like
billions of they give the billions of
parents opportunity to enjoy and be
inspired by that art and the art in this
context is music as of now but it's as
of the mission of certified it might
expand into other domain Zoom which we
are seeing it as in podcast
and if we talk about this brief
statement how does it
come up basically Spotify is trying to
match fans and artists in a very
personalized Way by their recommendation
algorithms their
suggested playlist
and if you know like some of the most
appreciated features are like you can
start your own radio from one song or
maybe you get delivered discover weekly
which gives you new music to try out and
exclude so this is all Spotify is doing
right now
oh that's that's really interesting uh
sort of I can see folks are replying on
chat there that they use Spotify and uh
yeah they have millions of songs but
some aren't there uh and we're going to
talk about that and also it is a great
app you know also the journey how
Spotify was built uh watching the
playlist on Netflix yes exactly like I
also watch that uh you know clearest the
playlist uh movie on Netflix and that
was pretty interesting but Spotify is
much more deeper than that right like
that is what we're going to explore how
exactly the record the competition
engine was built so uh I think this yeah
let's move on what is uh basically it
means uh to match an artist with a fan
in a personal relevant way how is
Spotify exactly doing it sort of
yeah so if you look at the artist
an artist creates a lot of tracks or
songs if we call it
and these songs are out there on the
Spotify for fans to explore
now how do these fans interact with
these songs they can search they can
create playlists they can ask other
people for recommendation and other
stuff but if we look at the scale of
these two
entities on Spotify there are about 300
million plus users on Spotify and at the
same time there are about 70 million
plus tracks on Spotify how would a user
explore all of these songs or maybe just
one percent of it it's a very it's a
task which might require us lifetime
bits for all of these songs and we might
not even know what can we listen what's
out there so
so the Spotify challenge is basically
matching these you know
amount of songs to proper users and they
use it they do it by using personalized
music recommendation which is basically
based on your taste based on your
preference based on what you like what
you don't like they will try to find out
a song which matches with your test
which matches with your preference and
for that they take in some user inputs
they take in your uh basically they
analyze your behavior they analyze what
kind of user you are they try to see
what other users are doing and try to
match up which we will we will explore
in detail when we go deeper into
recommendation systems and we talk about
how Spotify brings all of this into you
know reality when trying to recommend
music to different and in turn when it
fan listens to a music and it touches
their heart it kind of intrigues that
user it entrees that fan to go and
explore that artist which creates a very
personal ex you know connection between
these two entities like an artist and a
fan because they are just connected by
the music that they share between each
other so in in a way Spotify is just
creating that connection between two
human beings in a very artistic way
well that's pretty interesting like uh
just to see basically how Spotify does
it all uh and now moving on uh so there
is a challenge right like they have 70
million songs currently or you know on
on Spotify how does exactly Spotify
recommend music to users like can you
tell us about the recommendation
features sort of
yeah so how does Spotify recommend that
it's something study in deep but if we
just talk about some features or what we
see as a user like if I open Spotify app
and if I just look into the app what is
there there are a lot of things which
kind of you know like navigate me as a
user towards new music or if you would
say new artist
one of them being
discovered which is personalized
recommendation where we get you know
daily playlist or we discover weekly
which gives you new artist new music
which has come out in this week then
there is a feature called radio when you
just click on a song and you can start a
video for that selling right now you can
find related artists to the one you are
listening so let's say if you listen to
Pink Floyd or if you listen to it let's
jump in you can find actually artists
which are
have inspired them over the years and
have been inspired by Led Zeppelin so
it's kind of an interesting you know
like take for a music uh
uh fan to learn about all of these
things through music itself
and then there are playlists which are
based on your region demographic for
example Spotify has playlists like top
15 Euro up to 15 USA to 15 India hot 50
in India so these playlists basically
gives us an opportunity to you know go
and find something that we would want to
listen and cherish you know like just
for this five six seven minutes wow
that's pretty interesting I think we are
going to learn a lot about the
recommendation features which we have uh
now uh I think the question comes in
right what exactly is a recommendation
system I think I'm pretty sure folks
have a question exactly what exactly uh
does it recommend how does this work
what is this recommendation system can
you tell us about that
yeah if I simply put a recommendation
system is something which knows you too
well
where like too well that you don't even
know yourself through that level and
then it introduces you to new things
which you would not have thought about
like Steve Jobs has said people don't
know what they want until you show it to
them and this is what the recommendation
system does basically is it's if you
just put it in technical terms it's in
Labyrinth of AI algorithms and ml models
which will analyze users
preferences
like what kind of movie they like what
kind of products they buy what kind of
music they listen to and based on this
information it tries to recommend users
other things which are which might
alleviate the
user experience and in turn basically
bring in more business value to these
you know businesses which are out there
so in terms of Spotify
system is basically all what we see on
their app like discover weekly playlist
that they recommend the radio feature
anything that we use on Spotify is
driven
very common yes
system which is very straight and if we
talk about
how other Industries are using a
recommendation system basically I think
we all use it on in our day-to-day life
when we browse YouTube and YouTube
suggests are recommended for you or
similarly when net when we see something
on Netflix and Netflix recommend this
I
to be similar to what
to what we watched
similarly
Instagram when you browse one
real it's it's the power of
recommendation system it can at
sometimes
into into this uh basically continuous
stream of data
okay folks uh we were going through a
little bit of Hiccup here uh due to the
in electricity issue uh but I think that
is resolved so you will hear the voice
pretty uh clear now so just give us like
two minutes as we uh
okay awesome
I think my video should be visible now
it's okay uh for the folks who were uh
having issues with the voice I think it
should be resolved now because
I can quickly submit them in a minute if
you guys want it uh basically as we
talked recommendation system is
something which learns more about your
conferences
can you hear me
yeah I can hear you yeah your voice is
breaking a little can you just switch
your uh maybe internet uh now
because currently your voice is blinking
yeah I I just switched my internet you
can can you guys listen to me like I'm
available enough
and let me know if it breaks in between
again we can start over and I can repeat
whatever is not you know like
communicated properly so when we are
talking about recommendation system
basically let's talk about let's take a
scenario you have a friend who is a
really good Chef who is like one of the
most amazing Chef in this world and you
plan to visit him when you go to that
friend
that friend asked you basically what
kind of dishes do you like and you tell
them that I like steaks or I like pizza
or I like Biryani as it's popular in
India and because that Chef knows what
are the ingredients of these food items
that you mentioned
that Chef can cook a really nice dish
which basically has all these taste
profiles and spices and you know like
textures based on what you just told
them so it's like a ship here it's 45
employees a personal chef for everyone
which we'll ask you what kind of music
you like and then they will introduce
you to new music which might be similar
to what you just asked for and how do
they do it basically they derive the
ingredients of that music from
your preferences which we will talk
about in detail in uh in you know later
on and recommends you
new things to try on but yeah and it's
it's one of the things that we do and we
see recommendation system in other
places such as Amazon when you're buying
a product you see people have also
bought which is again a recommendation
system based on
you know like what you just bought same
goes for Netflix YouTube or which you
are a book reader you might find it in
place says like Goodreads where they
recommend you books based on what they
have liked
thank you so much for taking us through
the what exactly a recommendation system
is uh and also in between I can
understand uh there there was a little
bit disturbance in the voice part but
that is sorted uh in case you're with
something you can always put down your
questions in the Q a box and we'll take
it so don't worry about that now moving
on uh how does exactly a recommendation
system work sort of can you tell us
about it
yeah so I'll just give you an analogy
with this simple analogy like that will
try that will basically you know like
give you idea about how there's a
recommendation system but and then we
can go into the technical parts of it so
let's say as we talked about a chef
friend who is building or who is making
a really delicious dish for us and we
have just given them information about
our preferences that okay I like pizzas
and I like pizza which are little bit
cheesy it has some vegetables on it but
I don't like meat and you know like I
like crunchy business now this is all
the data that we have provided to ship
for the chef that they have to process
it first of all like what we have told
them so in that way basically if we talk
about
how a chef would go on to recommend you
a new dish first they will take in your
input which is called data preprocessing
and collection where they cut where
recommendation system collects your data
and tries to process it and fits into
the right places and sees if there is
anything missing which is worthwhile and
if it is missing they will try to you
know like find correlation through other
data points and in try to deduce that
value so here maybe in Pizza stems you
have not given uh you know like your
preferences about what kind of sauce do
you like on your pizza so maybe the chef
would try to interpolate that
information from what you have given to
them now comes to data exploration part
data exploration is basically
seeing that how the data looks like how
it fits in and you know just trying to
gain human level insights on that data
so we can go and build our own system
and in this particular example
the shift will try to you know like just
see all of these elements in their head
and see what can they make what can be
start you know like serving you
now if we go to the third stage of
recommendation system is that it is
feature extraction feature extraction is
nothing but you know like just getting
out the ingredients of that recipe so
what does a pizza require and what is
your preference so your preference is
what you have told them now the chef
will take all of these ingredients which
are features of the pizza and try to
build
a new prism which we which you may like
most probably and that is called Model
building and evaluation where they will
try to build a pizza based on features
that you've told them and once they have
done that they will serve that to you or
they will just taste it on their
themselves and see if that
recommendation was has worked out so
basically that is called evaluation it's
it is Chef himself tasting that wisdom
before it he serves you so that you
don't end up slapping them or you know
like just having a you know like losing
their credibility in in your mind so
this is what model building and
evaluation is now when we go to
recommendation if shift finds that this
pizza has all the qualities that you
have mentioned they will come and
recommend you that yourself
so this is when analogy if we talk about
technical Parts like data pre-processing
is nothing but cleaning and organizing
user data or song data in spotify's
context like what kind of what the what
metadata is available for the songs like
title genre
year of this production
ends things like that in terms of user
data it will be like where you come from
what age what kind of songs do you like
do you like
rock and roll or you like Hindi songs or
you like dance songs based on that it
will try you know like it will just
process that data when it comes to
exploration part
it will just you know like try to plot
these all of these data points into some
graphs and see okay what's the
correlation does does Hindi song go well
with rock and roll I don't think so it
doesn't go well there is a lot of you
know difference between that these two
entities so that's when data exploration
part when we come to features features
is nothing but the points that we talked
about like preferences characteristics
of the lyrics of the song
how long have you listened to it all of
these are features features are
basically what
is the ingredient of recommender system
and features are not just about the song
but also about the user so what kind of
user you are how much you listen to
songs what's your preference
what do you listen to when you go to
shower what do you listen to when you
study what do you listen to when you
drink a cup of coffee all of these
things are features about the user and
then when we come to model then
explorating other models such as like
you know there are different types of
models which we'll talk about but
exploring these models and evaluating
whether these models are giving you the
right output
so that you can recommend these uh songs
to user and when it comes to
recommendations it's just you know based
on what you have derived till now we
will filter out if the user has listened
to this particular song
I think we should not recommend it
because we have already know about it so
if I already know about pin code I don't
want to be recommended about them but I
might want to recommend get recommended
about something else maybe let's have
been maybe Rolling Stones so this is
what a recommendation part is
thank you so much Sora for taking us how
exactly the recovery system works uh and
uh the folks are very eager to actually
see a live demo of this uh so I would
recommend like roses have a little
patience we are almost there uh so uh we
will always also like we get to know
what exactly are the recommendation
system types can you take us through
that sort of
no I think uh people are very in in
heavy to see how to build this system so
I'll just keep it short there are three
types of primarily there are three types
of recommendation system where basically
there are more but we want we'll just
skip them over for now if we talk about
content based recommendation system that
will be like let's say if you like a
song let's say if you like uh weekend
song then basically this recommendation
system will find songs which are similar
to weekend like dark Punk or Frank Ocean
and they will try to recommend these
songs to you if we talk about
collaborative filtering it's more like
let's say if you meet a friend and you
tell that friend hey uh I've listened to
this you know like really cool band
which is like Daft Punk
Have you listened to it and your friend
says like yeah I am also listen to it I
really like it
Have you listened to that your friend
says no so basically that's a
collaborative filtering recommendation
system where you are recommending based
on similar users so your friend and you
like same kind of song
and you have listened to something which
they have not so you recommend them that
something which they have not listen to
and then there are Hybrid models which
try to basically you know like combine
these two models and recommend you
something based on similarity of the
song and also similarity of the user and
that's it
thank you so much for taking us through
that now uh can you tell us a little bit
about content base filtering
yeah if you look at the visuals like
it's very clear let's say if I read an
article
and there are similar articles like that
on the same website then that website
will recommend me the other article
which I have not read yet but I've liked
articles similar to that
so let's see if I like to read about
Cricket I might read one news about
Cricket how India are how Indian team is
performing you know and then basically
maybe if I'm reading it on Quick Info
then if info will go and try to find
similar artists articles based on Indian
team and cricket and they will try to
recommend you like when will you know uh
reshaps will be back in the team or what
are the chances of India winning the
World Cup which I think everybody might
have on their mind
so uh let's also talk about
collaborative building which you have uh
you know discussed before
yep so as we as I said earlier let's
let's say you meet a friend and you
share that I like reacts like pqrs and
your friend says that okay I like that
qrsd now if you look at it you both have
three dots in common it's not QRS
and you have not listened to p and your
friend has not listened to T so your
friend recommends you that hey we should
go and check out B and basically you'll
be like oh nice I by the way you can
also try this track key which I'm about
recently and this is what called
laborator filtering it's like two people
collaborating and trying to find out
what's not seen by both of them or one
of them
uh so we have talked a lot about the
recommended system and its types uh
before we move on to the live project
demo I would love to know from folks who
actually are paying attention uh let's
see how much Adventure are they paying
so just a quick poll uh before we move
on to the coding part so which
recommended system approach do we use
for our live promo of Music rainbow
system what exactly are we going to use
let us know on a quick poll on the
screen which you see right now uh the
first option is the content-based
filtering the second one is popularity
based ranking the third one is
collaborative filtering and the fourth
one is hybrid filtering so let's see how
much attention you have been paying to
the class here uh before we start the
life project demo so I can see the poles
are very quickly moving so that's great
we have gotten a very very active
audience here very active on the chart
by the way while you were speaking
so uh that's that's great uh I can see
most of the folks have already voted so
uh a few of the folks who are left I'll
be just keeping the poll open for 15
seconds more uh quickly tell us which
recovery system approach did we use for
our live project demo which we are going
to be using uh for a music recruitment
system
so we can see quick four options here
and you can quickly just go and select
an option which you feel is correct and
submit your answer there
awesome I can see folks I've already
voted but few of the folks who have not
voted I'll just give five seconds more
uh so we'll be closing the pool in five
four
three still moving two one okay let me
in the whole time
and share the results as well so uh I
sort of I I think you can see uh folks
have voted for content-based filtering
uh what is the correct answer tell us
uh
it's a very futuristic question but
still I think people are right about
that that's like prediction it's a
recommendation system so it's
content-based filtering oh awesome like
that's what we are gonna try oh so
people have been paying attention
basically what you've been talking about
that's great uh now let's move on uh to
the tracks on features can you tell us a
little bit about that yeah so as we were
discussing right like you find similar
songs so I I mean while I explain this
track for some features maybe why don't
you give a try in chat box and put out
how would you identify song A is similar
to song b like what are the things you
would use that will give you idea of
okay these two songs are similar
right let's go on about the features
part so a track basically or a song as
three types of data points one is
metadata which is very simple like the
distributor or the artist or even in
Spotify will try to find that data it's
it's basically titled release title
artist featured artists who are
songwriters release date genre
language instruments all of these things
which are out there which everybody
knows about you can just find that out
if you want to then if you go about
audio analysis that is basically when
Spotify receives a track from an artist
they will put it into their system and
dark system will try to analyze
the audio and try to derive some of the
things or features from there which are
basically can I dance on this song or
does does this song You Know uplift my
energy is it positive or negative Is It
You Know instrumental or is it just
acoustic is it vocal all of these things
are derived from that audio that
and then the third thing which is very
interesting concept which Spotify has
been trying to introduce later lately is
the NLP analysis which is nothing but
you know like if you take the lyrics of
a song or if you just take playlists
which have this song into them and if
you just read the title of that playlist
or if you just read the list of that
playlist based with natural language
processing you can actually derive what
kind of song There Is this where are
people putting it so for example if I
talk about you know mother Mary by
beetles it's something which a person is
listening to while they are down and
many people will have that playlist you
know like just to feel better
while they are listening to this song so
feel better might be the playlist name
now this Spotify will go and analyze all
these playlists and feel better is
something that they captured they will
tag that particular
label with this track and when you try
to find songs which are feel better you
might see that song into that experience
so this is how the NLP analysis work and
now Spotify combines all of these
NCS which other songs are similar to
that as people have mentioned that there
are cosine where you know like
relationship that came into a string a
lot of other stuff which we can use to
find you know like similarity between
these songs which will also be exploring
in our line demo
now when we talk about skills which are
required for such analysis which one if
you talk about metadata metadata is very
large sum of data that we have to
process so it is big data processing
data warehousing is something that we
need to learn how to store that data how
to process that data on the go with you
know like with quick speed is something
you should learn when you are learning
about a ml so that you can actually
build this system at the scale when we
talk about audio analysis to understand
whether this song is danceable or not
but what's the energy of the song
Spotify there's a lot of audio analysis
they do speech recognition and all of
this gives them labels or features about
that audio and then finally we talked
about NLP which is natural language
processing so that is something Spotify
does and apart from it we're crawling to
get more insights context about this
song how the community is actually
talking about it
and this feature basically when you talk
about when you get all these features
you can actually
uh
build a Content based filtering
content-based filtering recommendation
system that we talked about earlier
basically finding similar song to the
one you are listening to
well I think you can go to the next
slide this one
I think folks are actually responding to
you on Charter you ask them a question
as well maybe you can look through those
answers as well I mean well we can also
talk about the user features as well
I think a lot of weapons were really
spoken like beats lyrics is something
Spotify uses
and category all of these things are
very relevant for finding similar songs
so good job guys like you are already on
the path to become an AML engineer you
are just thinking now you just need to
learn the coding but
foreign
and song similarity let's talk about
user features so earlier we have had an
example of you know two friends talking
now friends know each other friends know
a lot of stuff about each other but
Spotify doesn't know about you doesn't
know about the other person How would
how are they gonna see if these two
users are listening to similar songs so
I guess we derived the features for
songs similarly Spotify derives features
for users and how do they do it one is
explicit
and other one is implicit again I would
want people to give a try on how would
you find similar users based on their
music taste
so
while you do that we can just go and
talk about explicit features Excellence
features are features which are declared
but we use like if I log into Spotify
they will ask my age they will ask or
they will get to know where I come from
at times when 45 was older they used to
ask your music preference what kind of
genre you like a lot of music system
also do that and this is very explicit
like I'm declaring that okay I like
xyzing music I like arm or I like you
know uh Village or I like Bob Dylan so
these are the things I am giving Spotify
that okay these are my preferences and
these are my artists now implicit
features are something which
we don't declare out there to Spotify
but once you start using their app
Spotify gets to know about this how do
they know about us basically the song
that you play the like button that you
can click on the playlist that you see
how much
of duration Have you listened to that
song
what's your genre of reference basically
based on the songs that you have liked
and
all of these you know like behaviors
give Clues to Spotify and that maybe
this maybe sort of light not just Bob
Dylan maybe like you know like
um
Jimmy Page as well or maybe just you
know like he likes uh
I'm going blank for the names of the why
don't you guys why not ask the folks
like what song do you actually like what
is your favorite song so yeah basically
you guys can recommend me songs based on
what I'm telling you that would be
collaborative filtering based on user
features and that's a very good idea and
if we talk about skills that you are
used in these features or deriving these
features basically
one is data collection and data
processing again as we talked about
songs as well and then there is in
implicit features it's about data
analysis so basically taking that user
Behavior analyzing
how this user behaves and then machine
learning models to you know create
profile points for such users so this is
about user features when you use these
features you are creating a
collaborative recommendation system so
if we all in this call decide to
recommend songs for each other based on
your preference we will be creating a
probability recommendation system
it won't be scalable though but it will
still be a recommendation system
awesome uh I think uh folks have been
eagerly waiting for this uh so let's go
through the live project demo uh sir can
you share your screen and take us to the
live project demo for how exactly we
build a Spotify like a commercial engine
I'll just stop sharing so you can share
meanwhile folks
uh would love to know what exactly
questions do you have uh I'm getting a
lot of messages on chart here I am so
sorry we might miss it because we get a
lot of messages here so just to help me
out uh to help me out in getting your
queries cleared please go and put down
your questions in the Q any box so q a
box is not the chat box it is a q a box
you will see on your screen you can just
immediately go and ask a question which
you have and we will have a special
duration for the Q a part and I'm pretty
sure while you know is it playing the
live coding as well of uh this project
I'm pretty sure you will have those
questions as well so please go and put
down your positions in the Q a box thank
you so much
go ahead
and we'll be seeing I'll be walking you
through the code that is written here
and also you will also get to know what
skill set that are being used here
you know like I'll just give you a quick
brief about what kind of skills I might
be using here
so let's get started
basically once when we start building
any any start writing any code
we need to import certain libraries or
I'm not sure if you are familiar with
libraries but libraries are just you
know pre-written codes that you can use
in your code and you don't have to write
anything from scratch
and here we are using numpy and pandas
numpy and pandas are basically data
analysis and exploration libraries in
Python same for C bone and plotly is
something which we use for the data
visualization
and we'll be using sqln which will give
us algorithms that we will be using you
know to build our content-based
recommendation system
so let's get started I've imported some
libraries here uh if you want you can
just take a look at it I mentioned the
libraries that I'm using and
the second thing once we get the
libraries if we go to this you know like
thing where our recommendation system
works we talked about data
pre-processing and data collection so
this part is about data processing and
collection where I am importing data
from spotify's data set if any of you is
interested into where I got this data
from you can go to spotify's developer
page and get all of this data from there
where they give you data about songs
they give you data by song genres they
give you data by song here so it's
readily available in spotify's developer
page
so I've imported some of the data here
and data is basically nothing but list
of songs genre data is nothing but list
of zombies that are there and some
metadata about it will explore the title
and year data is so here did basement
zones degrees genre released what is
popular in that time
and as we have gotten the data now we
need to know what is there without that
we won't be able to know we will or you
know like strategize about what
recommendation system are you gonna
build so let's just take a look at the
data or sum Theta that we imported
scientists I've just done prints
data.info here
and I've gotten
you know like some of the information
which is basically the header of that
file
and it says that there are there is
valence there is ear acousticness artist
sensibility name mood liveness loudness
all of this data available for the songs
that we are gonna you know like run our
algorithm
and same goes for genre data that we
have imported let's just see that so if
we just look at it I have just run the
code and if it says we have done this in
again similar data points like songs for
those of us
and if we talk about here here is the
similar data it's just the song has been
replaced by year and in that here
basically let's say for 2022 what kind
of songs were there mostly Circle
stickness dance ability energy
instrumental language what sounds so
popular in that way it's the data
program
and as we have given going through all
the data points you've seen what's there
in the data now we can think about what
can we build so as we already have all
of this information we just track
features of some features that we talked
about earlier let's just you know like
uh
move on and see oh sort of so sorry for
interrupting uh is there any possibility
we can zoom it a little uh someone has
asked on the chat or they can zoom with
themselves you know whatever works so uh
I think yeah it's quite possible
okay yes yes please continue
so now we are using a library called
Yellow Brick which will give us the
information about
correlation of these features with each
other so why are we doing that basically
if I have a long list of features right
now we were just looking at 15 20 Pages
you know but in real world or when
Spotify builds that algorithm they have
millions of features about one
particular song
now you can't just use all of these
features at a time and some of the
features might not be very useful for
you how do you find that you find the
correlation between different features
and see if there are two features highly
correlated with each other we may not
even use need to use one of them which
is less useful for us so we are just
using this yellow brick library and
trying to find the correlation between
these
features and see what can we use what do
we know so if we look at it uh or you
know like
this is this is a correlation for all
the features that we have and it's this
correlation is by popularity like how
much year is correlated with popularity
how much mode is related e is we could
explicit duration balance all of these
things are related to popularity so and
we can see that acousticness is you know
inversely related to popularity and here
is very highly related to popularity but
we might not
get some information from it but we just
know that this this is the popularity or
correlation with popularity of all these
features now we will have to understand
the data in visual terms like we can't
go through the full data points in our
database and see okay this music is
related to music
because that would take the ideas for
any human being
so we'll just start analyzing and seeing
what can we understand from the data
that we have
so
if we look at it if we will just first
go through music over time how it has
changed from 1921 to 2000 2020 and for
that I'll just created a function which
will which is basically let's get
indicate this will get the decade from
the year so if I just put in 2009 it
will give me 22 000 basically is
indicate program
and
I have applied that function to all of
the data
of here that I have in in my database
and I uploaded that out
so if we look at it
it's basically says that
these are the number of songs that have
been released overall 2000 2020 has or
2020s have little less because it has
not been completed yet but all the
decades have a high number of major
points especially starting from 1950s
when the music Revelation became so
we'll just take a look at that
now if we talk about sound features of
these data points
we look we can see that acousticness has
decreased over the years and energy has
increased in music over the years
basically in 1940s it was less energetic
and now people are having more blastful
music which gives you know electric and
similarly other genres have been shown
here so you can take a look for it look
at it for for a while and we can just
like if we see dance ability has
remained almost same over the years and
which is kind of you know like obvious
because we all loved it as
now let's talk about characteristics of
different genres like how different
genres have different types of energy
dancibility and acousticness in them so
I've just taken the genre data and I've
loaded the data
with their
you know like
features of music that was produced in
this in in these soldiers so if I talk
about South African house music it has a
lot of danceability and a lot of
positiveness balance is nothing but how
positive a song is
if I talk about Chinese Electro pop it
is a little bit you know like down there
and but still has a dancer between that
and it is very high energy music so all
of these journals are plotted here with
what kind of music was generated in
these numbers
now we have gone through how music were
produced over the years we have gone
through how genres have different types
of music in them let's start building
more understanding towards how one genre
relatively relates with another one so
how close
a Turkish idiom is to Chinese Electro
pop because those two are very close
because there is no acoustic-ness and
low balance and high density in both of
them so these two are very close but we
will get to see how close these
different genres are to each other
so for that we are just using one
algorithm K means clustering algorithm
which basically is nothing but uses your
data and normalizes it and then tries to
Cluster different types of data points
into their relativity so basically how
close one data point is to another
has in imported k-means algorithm I am
imported
uh to load it out here and I'm using
that algorithm on John this data and
I've created one more
basically
column in my algorithm which is cluster
and it will give me the cluster of each
genres that I have created and that will
be predicted by cluster pipeline which
is nothing but a feature of pipe you
know like as quickly to give us
information about
which cluster this particular genre
falls into
and once you have done that let's look
at how these clusters look like in real
life
so this is the plot of all the genres
that we have taken and we can see that
this particular Virgin Island Reggae is
very close to Geo metal Japanese metal
and is also very close to mashup and
gurasha that we talked we looked at
earlier and similarly all these if you
see look at the colors these colors are
nothing but genres different genres and
they have been plotted here based on
their music features and we can see
which genre is closer to each other and
this will give us uh give our
recommendation an idea about let's say
this person listens to pop or Indie pop
what should I recommend to that person
so based on the closeness of the other
genres the recommendation system will be
coming to other songs
now we have done that for genres now we
will do the same thing for songs so we
know that okay maybe you know like
Reggie pop and J-pop are kind of similar
to each other now let's see how songs
are similar to each other because that
will give us more data points to do
Computing for the recommendation and it
will allow us to recommend the right
kind of music to the user so here we go
for clustering of these songs with again
using K means and we'll plot the same
game is graph here and we can see all
these songs are plotted here with
different dots and
every dot represents one music so if you
look at this whole cluster
a lot of songs are kind of same even
though they are independent on us if you
look at this particular thing where I'm
pointing my cursor you can see there are
Battle Cry Paradise City and receivers
Here I Am to Worship these are all rock
songs which are similar to this
particular blue one which is bodies dead
or Islander different or through the
fires and Frames these are the new
generation rock music so this is modern
rock related to how classic rock
so now let's think about
how are you going to build a
recommendation system we have
come to know how songs are related to
each other they have come to know how
genres are related to each other now if
I give you a song
what will you use to find give me
another three songs similar to that
maybe you can you guys can give an
attempt in the chat and put out what
will you use to give me recommendations
for next five songs
okay folks you can tell us on chart here
what exactly we will use
I can see responses coming in
yeah yeah we will use some questions
definitely but song is also related to
jointer so we will also be using genre
clustering at the same time and we might
also use the information related to be
in here that is there
to to get some more similarity and maybe
you know like recommend something let's
say if you're listening to something
from 1960s you can recommend something
similar in 2020 so there is less likely
or more likelihood of you actually going
and seeing that artist live
so let's go
so we have seen that genres and songs
are you know like which are similar
types are clustered together and we
already we can also like you know from
our own experience see that okay yeah a
song Single sound similar or write I
like so a song and the other songs I'm
similar to that I might like that as
well and same goes for its own does now
moving forward we are gonna use a
library called sportp which is just a
python client for you know just
accessing spotify's web API
why are we using spotify's web API
basically because if I give a song to my
recommended system my recommended system
will be able to go and find the songs
that it recommends for me from spotify's
catalog and it will be able to give me
information about those songs
and for using spotify's developer API we
again have to go to spotify's developer
page and create our account once we
create our account on that you will get
a client ID which is nothing but your a
token basically it's a token given by
Spotify to you so that you can use their
web API later on
so we are installing this 45 40p Library
here and once you install that
we will go and basically provide our
credentials for
Spotify account so I'm just giving my
credential I have not kept those visible
here because that's very basically
anybody can misuse so you should also
practice this when you are coding that
you don't give out your authorization
token or IDs which are basically similar
to your password for anything let's see
you won't give your password for email
to anyone similarly you don't give your
password for or authentication token for
any of the API that you use
now I am writing a function which will
be basically which is called find songs
and this function will take a name and
the year of the song and it will
recommend me another five songs based on
that particular track that I provided
so it will just
basically I'm searching for in spotify's
database for the song and if I don't get
the result I will return them so that my
code don't cache let's see if I enter
entering some random name instead of
maybe come as you are from Nirvana I
entered go as you want from Nirvana
there is no song like that so there is
no point of recommending anything on top
of it so it will just remove that now
I'm just taking the result which is the
song that I've gotten from Spotify to
get more information about it
and
from that track I'm trying to get audio
features that we talked about earlier
right dance ability and then see valence
and all of that stuff I am trying to
detect that using this audio feature
function
and once I get that I will also try to
get the data about some like what's its
name here and you know whether it's an
explicit song or not what's the duration
in popularity
and then I will use my audio features
library and provide it
with the
all of this song data so that I can
actually
create communities forms
so I've written this song data function
which will which is nothing but using
the older function that I've written
earlier and now we are getting mean
Vector which is nothing but you know
like tries to find
the vector function for the song or
feature function for the song so that
you can relate it with other songs and
for each song it will give us the
clustering or the near ability for or
similarity for other sound so that we
can see if I should recommend it or not
and I'm using this get mean function so
I am given I have given it strong list
in 45 data and based on that it will
recommend me uh it will give me the
similarity of this one Latin dictionary
is nothing but you know like just the
data that I've gotten is not one
dimensional if I have to present it to
any user it won't be visible so I'm
using platin dictionary to you know like
just put out data in a consumable format
and the final song Final thing is
recommended song it's taking the song
list it's taking a Spotify and it's
taking the number of songs that I want
to recommend and based on that
it will go it will use these functions
basically it will use get mean Vector to
find the similar songs
and it will also use uh similar function
for finding similar genres and find the
songs from there so once I run run this
function
I will get the recommended songs so I am
giving it five songs to recommend this
is my input if I just give this five
response to my recommendation system it
will give me other songs which are
similar to that so if I'm providing it
come as you are as one of the songs
smells like the inspiration all
apologies and stay away all of these are
Nirvana song and if I just
put it down into my system it will
recommend me songs like
Life is a Highway from cars or maybe of
Wolfman from Metallica or something like
you from Peter gun so it has just given
me all of these songs and this is my
recommendation system working right here
so any questions you have guys or
anything you want to understand more
feel free to us
uh uh thank you so much I are getting a
lot
a lot uh chat here as well in the Q a
box uh I would recommend folks to put
your questions in the Q a box because
you're missing questions here uh let me
share my screen once again uh so yeah I
think I've seen a few questions I see
that
this I do understand these codes are
very complex and that's why maybe you
know like
first making yourself familiar with uh
how data exploration data cleaning works
and then getting theoretical knowledge
or how you know like aim and models work
what do you need to do how do you find
something similar or what is even
something similar name to you what is
the recommendation system we have talked
about these things in Breeze but you may
have to go deeper actually to understand
any of this and build it on your own
it's not very difficult it's it's very
easy path but you have to go step by
step to actually be able to write all of
this code so don't worry if you don't
understand the code right now it was
just a demo to
make you understand that you can also
write a code which is being used by a
company like Spotify you may not be able
to write X as expensive as them but you
can start writing code like that and
maybe one day you can meet with other
folks who are you know as talented as
you are and build something
okay uh I think uh let's go
question here
which attention where you're paying you
know when server is doing a live
demonstration so you can see a quick
poll on your screen right now uh and it
is a it is a question leading to the
live magic demo itself so it's a very
easy question so let's see uh you know
what you guys have to share so uh the
question is in a hybrid equipment system
what does the term hybrid refer to so
you can see if four quick options here
select the one which you feel like you
know is the correct answer and it's okay
to be wrong as well it's okay just give
it a try this will help you understand
uh you know the project mode
so in a hybrid recruitment system what
does the term hybrid refer to so you can
see a quick poll on your screen here you
can quickly go and select an option uh
which you feel is correct and I can see
you already most of the folks have voted
and so folks are pretty quick here and I
can see one option getting the high
intelligence and machine learning's
postgraduate program uh before that uh
let's just uh see like what responses we
have gotten here
I'll give five seconds more for folks
who have not voted and there are only
few folks left uh so you can see a quick
poll on your screen so I'll be closing
the poll in five seconds
so five
four three two one let me quickly share
the results
uh I can I think we can see uh blending
various recommendation techniques
getting the highest number of votes uh
what is the current answer
it is it is the right answer blending
various recommendation techniques to
create a hybrid recommendation system
and everybody who has gotten it right
thank you for paying attention and
you have like one step ahead on on your
part to become a and then you know
engineer
let's move on
about
gdamn uh so what up to date skills are
needed to become an eim a practitioner
it's a good question but I will so I
will talk about the skills that we need
to learn but there is one more thing
that we need to keep in mind when we are
learning anything or when we are you
know like trying out in things so there
is no end to anything in AIM or or even
software engineering or even being an
artist you keep learning new things
which are coming out there so right now
is it's uh generating AI like chart CPT
and you know like other model segments
and me and things which are basically in
the
state of the art
AI models out there but there will be
more there will be much more extensive
or you know like complete em what is
coming up in the future
but to begin with
machine learning and Ai and data science
is a very
is a subject which takes you to uh which
needs you to you know dwell into Data a
lot and for that you have to have some
foundations and statistics and
Mathematics
to be able to think in a way that will
help you build models that will help you
come up with some ideas or help you
understand why certain algorithm might
be better than this one Accord
then it's
very given thing that if you want to
build anything you need to learn code
and In This Moment python is one of the
most easiest way to learn
coding and at the same time python
python is one of the most used
coding or programming language in aims
space
so that's one of these these are the two
things you need to learn and you know
like just absorb as much as possible
then if we talk about
what kind of things
are there like lending methods or you
know like
skills other skills that you need to
learn
as we talked earlier as well you need to
be very
frequent with data so data processing
Big Data supervised learning and
supervised learning and simple learning
recommendation system these are
theoretical aspects but it should be
aware of these and you should be able to
you know like give your input on which
one will be better which one won't be
better you should build some mini
projects on all of these methods so that
you can get understanding how it works
how can you leverage when it when a real
life problem comes into you you know
comes on your face and then there are
Advanced topics such as deep learning
neural networks relative AI computer
vision NLP and these are the things
which are like you know like or selling
items of AI which everybody would have
heard of
even if they are not aware of how AIML
works like neural network is something
we all keep hearing or generating AI or
the other name of it is chart GPT or you
know like uh other word which is
released by Google
similarly for computer vision computer
vision is heavily used by Tesla in their
self-raid in cars or in a lot of robot
you know like AI based robots which try
to accomplish certain tasks computer
vision is one of the things that use the
NLP and speech recognition is again a
very interesting topic where you can
basically translate if I'm talking in
English and somebody wants to listen to
him me in Hindi or you know like Spanish
they can use NLP and speech Republic
formation and convert what I'm saying on
the go to their preferred language so
these are the very state-of-the-art you
know technical things which are being
worked on right now but to get there you
have to start from Foundation understand
how things work what can I do what how
can I build certain things have
theoretical knowledge build some
projects on top of it and then go to
Advanced topics
through that
you can let us know in chat thank you so
much
now uh we have talked about the skills
we have talked about you know what uh
profile also you can take up an AI and
machine learning uh to become a
practitioner in that so what exactly is
stopping you uh from uh you know taking
up the AIML certification and also
becoming a practitioner in that so let
us know you can see a quick pull in the
screen so I want to know what is the
biggest concern here what exactly is
stopping you from taking the AML
certification will be talking about so
uh so I can see though uh what's coming
in already so this this one is a
multiple choice question you can select
multiple options here
so folks are pretty quick here they are
very quickly like choosing the options
here uh so we will keep this whole life
to 15 seconds of if the folks have not
voted and uh meanwhile you're voting if
you're already on voting just to let you
know that we're getting a lot of
interesting questions in the Q a part uh
so please do and um you know put down
your questions in the Q a box uh if
you're putting all your questions in the
chat I am so sorry we might miss it so
please do me a favor and put it there in
the Q a box so I will help you uh in
getting query answered by sort of yeah
okay so let's see what is the biggest
concern while taking up an Amir
certification
so do you have a concern that you can
find a fully comprehensive curriculum uh
in that particular course the second one
I don't have the Practical exposure I
need to become job ready the third one
is I find it difficult to learn from the
pre-recorded videos and the last one is
my work schedule won't allow me enough
time for learning so whichever is a
suitable option which you feel like this
is the biggest concern you know stopping
at home taking the AML certification so
please go and vote for that option I can
see most of the folks have already voted
in uh so uh meanwhile you're doing that
we'll be taking the Q a uh questions
very soon uh and we are very excited to
take this question because that gives
you a very interesting question in the Q
a box here so that's amazing
so I'll be closing the pole in five
seconds so five four three
two one let me in the whole
let me share the results for you folks
so we can see the biggest concern here
is I wouldn't get the Practical exposure
I need to become job ready
and uh I can see that uh
the second biggest concern is uh
basically my work student wouldn't allow
me enough time for Learning and
similarly I can't find a fully
comprehensive curriculum and few of them
have said that I find it difficult to
learn from pre-recorded videos so thank
you so much folks for telling us your
biggest concern now moving on uh we have
a program by Purdue uh in post strategy
program and AI machine learning and this
is in collaboration with IBM uh in this
program you get comprehensive curriculum
with an industry aligned learning path
and also you get to access to integrated
case studies Hands-On projects or
practical experience uh which Sarah has
shown a live demo of about as well one
of the projects uh and also you get
access to online live worship classrooms
with peer image instructional
interaction and also you'll get a
flexible to fit lifestyle and schedule
as well the program duration for this
one is 11 months and you can complete
this by giving only five to ten hours
per week so that's pretty interesting uh
sort of I would just ask one question uh
that uh what level of productivity uh
one should you know keep up when taking
up a course like this uh by basically
you need to give at least five to ten
hours a week right so what would you
suggest like in your own term like if
you would have you know learned
something and you know studied something
what level of productivity did you have
what motivated you to keep going
uh for me one of the motivation is like
I love to learn tips so always try to
take out time to you know learn
something new
and secondly like as
this program requires almost 10 hours
per week
I would try to I mean if I was in this
place or in in courses I've taken past
I've taken up most of time on weekends
you know like afternoon weekend
afternoons or best time for you to do
anything and there you can take out
minimum three two three hours per day so
if you if you put enough efforts on
weekend you can just put in like maybe
30 45 minutes on weekdays and get this
thing done you don't have to stress
yourself while you're working on your
own you know like job
you can just take out 30 minutes 45
minutes that can be while you're
committing to work or while you are
cooking something in the sports video
keep it in mind and then maybe take
another 10-15 minutes to revise what
you've learned over the weekdays and
then we use weekends to build things to
learn more deeply
thank you so much for helping us with
that now uh what exactly we're getting
from this program so you will be getting
a Purdue business and this is post
certificate as well and you'll be
getting uh IBM post certification as
well you'll be getting access to 25 plus
uh Hands-On projects indicated labs and
uh we add Capstone project in three
different domains you're only getting
master classes with Purdue and Industry
experts and career assist program now
talking about the Purdue University
Advantage so Purdue is a 151 year old
University which actually rans in one of
the top public us universities and also
the Purdue graduate programs give you a
joint a produce Implement certificate
and master class uh with Purdue faculty
and also access to the Purdue alumni
association uh also having a party
University on your CV is a prestigious
accomplishment recognized worldwide so
that's a really good advantage to have
when you see I must say and also uh I
think few of the folks have asked about
the eligibility and very excites so you
need to have a prior uh in her knowledge
of mathematics and programming and you
need to have high school diploma or
equivalent to at least 18 years of age
uh and uh two or more years experience a
work experience preferred uh not
mandatory so uh just a question I think
we have gotten in the Q a box uh that
sort of like uh why does having a little
bit knowledge about mathematics and
programming helps you you know while
you're taking up an EML certification
uh basically if I just like as we talked
about it earlier like you need to write
code
and for you to need to like be able to
write code you need to understand how
programming languages work how you can
make your code efficient how do you make
yourself not commit mistakes which are
you know like gonna mess up with your
code so no matter how efficient how
accurate code model that you can think
of in your head but if you can't write a
code you won't be able to put out
anything out there in the world
so that's one of the requirements of
programming when we come to mathematics
mathematics puts you understanding of
why am I using K means listening what is
K means why am I normalizing data why do
I need normalized data you know a lot of
questions easily from your way when you
are building organization system when
you have data which is not you know like
consistent across you can use your
mathematical understanding to come up
with something which can help you make
that data consistent
so all of these things help in
making your career in AML really
efficient and you know Worthy
but at the same time
I wouldn't say if I was in a place where
I didn't know mathematics and
programming which I was a few years back
I didn't know any of programming and
Mathematics
I you can still learn all of these
things on the go and it's not very hard
like mathematics what do you use in
machine learning for building such code
is just high school or you know like
maybe graduation level algebra that's
not very hard to learn and similarly
programming is something which is basic
programming you're not building very
extensive softwares with software
Engineers actually going with they're
building some tools and you know trying
out something so these are
foundational knowledge you need to have
and you shouldn't you know like shy away
from taking this course or pursuing your
career in AI ml even if you don't know
any of that just keep learning and you
will be there
awesome thank you so much for answering
that and we're getting similar questions
in the universe which I'm taking you
some time so if you have any question uh
for the AIML uh Purdue post casual
program so please put that in the clear
box and we will help you answer it
anything into the career in AIML as well
so now how this program exactly prepares
you so uh how this program builds your
skill uh AI skills step by step uh sorry
can you quickly take us through these
steps
yep
so as we talked about you know skills
required for this course this program
exactly does that and it takes you step
by step towards your overall goal of
becoming an AI and reaching it and if we
talk about how it does that basically
the scores will teach you python for
data science how to use Python library
is like numpy and Paradise which are the
most fundamental libraries out there for
AIML
and then how applied data science can be
done with python again so in that you
will learn how to process data of main
data how to visualize it explore
something because you will have large
data set to work with
you we will need to do exploration you
will need to find how it looks like and
with this particular
you know like course in this curriculum
you can actually do that then you will
learn about machine learning which is
the next step of the data science you
learn about machine learning models like
supervised learning and supervised
learning and reinforcement learning that
we talked about earlier which will give
you
the foundation for learning deeper
conception animals which are which again
comes a deep learning which will you
will use with Terrace tensorflow which
are again highly used tools in AIM in
Space by a lot of professionals and
researchers
and then there are Advanced deep
learning Concepts such as neural
networks and computer vision that you
would be learning and finally to sum it
all up and you know like because you've
gathered all the ingredients for the
recipe you will be doing a Capstone
project to make a delicious dish out of
it so as you as a lot of you were asking
how do I build a model or how do I build
every Foundation system like that
you can you will have all the
opportunity to do
all your fulfill all your wishes you
know or build something that you have
been designing for in this Capstone
project
apart from it there are electives which
will make you
acquainted and you know like familiar
with a lot of other new things which are
out there in the market such as chart
dpd NLP and speech recognition
then reinforcement lending that we
talked about the machine okay and GitHub
is again necessary because it allows you
to collaborate with other programmers
encoders in your team because you can't
write all of that code by your own you
need to collaborate address
and then there are AI enable master
classes per due and then there will be
really interesting industry master class
which will give you insights about
what's actually happening in the
industry right now by professional stem
cells
so overall it's something you should be
looking forward
thank you so much Sarah for taking us to
that also about the electives they are
optional so it will it comes as a part
of the program and it is included in the
program fees as well you don't have to
pay anything extra for that so if you
are taking it up that's great uh so now
also moving on to what tools and
platforms you will learn so uh I think
uh the current one we have done in
Python so you'll be learning python
Django tools like opencv tensorflow
chart GPT which saurabh has already
mentioned open AI gym kubernetes and
many more
also uh we'll be working on industry
align projects for your portfolio I
think we have to show you a very quick
demo of one of the projects you get to
work on uh which is quite interesting so
obviously there are many more projects
which will help you uh with basically
getting job ready
and also a caption project as well uh so
uh sorry can you tell us how does having
a caption project in your scene uh
prepares you for the real world uh and
when you're trying to apply for jobs you
know post certification
Yeah so basically
you know like
you can learn all about streaming from
YouTube videos but if you don't go out
and dive into a swimming pool you would
never know if you've learned swimming or
not
same goes for anything that you learned
so if you learn aim into your classroom
building a Capstone project gives you
confidence gives you
understanding of how things are brought
into the real world how something which
is an idea can be converted into
something that is actually working and
can be used by other people
and at the same time it's a credibility
Factor because if a recruiter sees that
you have built something you have a
knowledge or something let's say if you
build a recommendous system which is
which will be much more detailed and
extensive than what we have you know
built today then any recruiter would be
willing to give you a chance for the job
projects are something I think are much
more important than any of the learning
because it gives you a chance to put or
you know trickle down all that lining
into something real
well that's that's really great uh thank
you so much all of us uh taking us to
that now we'll be talking about industry
experts instructors will be getting
access to uh Rockies you can see is an
AML trainer with 24 years of experience
you can see a little girl who is a data
science instructor with 16 plus years of
experience you can see uh nitin guzra
was a Founder at crime league with 15
plus years of experience and Simon as
well who's the senior data science
consultant
uh we will be dog sharing learner
outcomes as well so a very interesting
card uh thing that our previous classes
have consistent of Learners from World
Class A Class organizations and diverse
Industries like I.T software product
manufacturing Pharma Healthcare BFS and
others and also they come from companies
like Sac Coast Ridge Wells Fargo Target
uh Siemens Infosys Ames IBM HP many more
than that and uh we have learner reviews
which you can see on the screen from
Chris Hayes who actually was able to
learn a bunch about programming in
Python along the way and also is
basically looking forward to learning
more in this particular field you can
see Philly Theodore uh basically
surveillance course uh gave him a basic
knowledge required for start to build
his own products and models and also uh
he basically uh is praising the trainer
as well who actually helped with very
clear you know explanations and uh gave
us gave them a lot of tips as well
because he shallender Kumar here uh who
actually uh learned the Deep learning
with tensorflow hosts which was handed
pretty well by the instructor he
recommends and also you get access to
singular's career as a service which
helps you in your job sense in this you
can access to the job portal through
resume rabbit uh you can access to
resume review and rewrite service by top
resume and also one-on-one interview
Service uh by Toppers top interview so
that's needed right when you're out
there looking for a job and you're
giving to use so this always helps now
uh now let us know like are you
interested in enrolling to the program
you can see a quick bowl on your screen
so I can see if you folks have asked
about the program fee and the cohort
starting up so please let us know before
that before we actually share that in
the next slide uh like about the program
structure program fee where is the
cohort starting uh how can you enroll
into that so before that I would love to
know if you are interested in doing the
program you can see I'm going to Quality
screen if you're interested in enrolling
to the program of pro strategy program
in artificial intelligence and machine
learning by Purdue you can select the
option base here so uh I can see folks
are already voting for the poll here and
I can see a lot of interest towards the
party program as well in artificial
changes machine learning meanwhile uh
just to let you know we are taking up
the Q a questions next so please uh go
and put your queries there related to
artificial intelligence career uh you
know if you have any questions if you're
transitioning to that career if you have
any questions related to the program you
can put down those questions there as
well so you'll be taking those questions
very soon
okay I can see most of the folks have
already voted but I'll give like 15
seconds more for folks who would like to
enroll into this program you can just
select an option yes and a quick pull on
your screen before we move forward to
the Q a part
foreign
program please let us know interest so
accordingly you know we can reach out to
you and obviously give you a much more
detailed walkthrough of the program as
well
you can see here quick quality screen so
I'll be closing the poll in five seconds
few of the folks have not voted please
go and immediately Vote or would you
like to enroll in the into the produce
iaml program
okay I can see a lot of interest towards
the enrollment so that's great but I
have to close this poll in five seconds
now so five
four three two one thank you so much
everyone
now moving on
to uh the program fee and schedule uh so
uh in basically obviously the program is
open for the rest of the world uh and
India as well so we have the program fee
here for USA so it is four thousand five
hundred dollars and uh for a few of the
folks asking about if if there are any
financing options available so we do
have that and in this uh you have
financing available for as low as 396
dollars per month and in India uh we
have uh the program fee of one lakh 49
9999 and here also we have like
financing options available for as low
as
5105 per month and also for folks who
have joined from other parts of the
world you can go and look for the
program and you'll find those uh
basically fee structure for that I'll
share this that towards the end so don't
worry about that
now uh talking about the enrollment
steps uh there are very three simple
steps to enroll uh here all you need to
do is you need to submit an application
to ask us at simpliano.net uh after once
your application is submitted we will
basically take it for a review and based
on that we'll be sending an admission
offer later and also a siblings learning
consultant will be getting in touch with
you uh for the basically programmer and
take you and take you on a basically
walk through the program in much more
detail if you have any more questions so
uh the question I think someone asked in
the Q a box the upcoming code which we
have is the induction is happening on
September 5th and the classes for this
one will be starting on October 21st uh
just to let you know we have very
limited seats like we only take 25 to 30
Forks per cohort so uh just to make sure
that you're getting all the attention
that is needed uh so please uh if you're
looking for starting it to the this
particular code so I would recommend
like hurry up and uh your seats there so
now um basically how when do you plan to
enroll in the uh produce AIML program so
please let us let us know so you will
see a quick poll on the screen right now
so for for the folks I can see most of
the folks have shown interest in the
produce AIML program uh you can just see
quick goal on your screen where you can
see four options if when do you plan to
enroll into the produce AML program uh
are you Bank enroll immediately are you
planning to enroll within three months
are you planning to enroll within six
months or more than six months from now
so all four options are there uh you can
go and quickly vote for folks who have
shown intention to the eam is uh produce
uh postgraduate program so I can see
folks are already sharing when do they
want to start uh that's great uh I would
recommend for the folks who are still
thinking about it okay I'm not sure if
it immediately within three months I
would recommend to select the within six
months to more than six months from an
option because you will lose out of the
bonus or whatever she will get you know
post webinar so I would highly recommend
that so to vote for it and anyways
you'll be getting much more detailed
walk throughout the program right so if
you have any questions you will get your
questions answered there as well before
you take up the program
I can say most of the folks have already
shared their interest when exactly do
this soon plan to enroll
okay so I'll be closing the poll in 10
seconds so for few of the folks who have
not voted please go and immediately vote
this will help us understand when we
exactly plan to enroll and I would
recommend not to lose out of the bonus
offer but I didn't need this webinar
okay uh I can see most of the folks have
already voted in so uh I would be
closing the poll in 10 seconds so
quickly just go and let us soon plan to
enroll I think the produce aim post
graduate program
five
four three two one
thank you so much for sharing you know
when exactly do you plan on enrolling
that will really help us uh when we are
reaching out to you now coming to the Q
a part I think folks have been waiting
early for this sort of so let us take
the Q a uh questions from the Q a box
now uh for the folks who are basically
waiting uh you know like for the further
questions to get answered we'll be
taking those questions but please go and
put down your questions in the cleaner
box while we are taking down questions
in case you have not done it yet uh so
uh let's start with I think I can see a
very interesting question here by madhav
syrup uh I'm asking about okay okay I
think
okay I think it's asking what the
webinar recording so webinar recording
you'll be getting uh post uh webinar and
uh you can view it and you want if you
want you can go through it in much more
detail I can see a few of the questions
about the webinar recording and the
certificate as well guys you'll be
getting those as well
okay uh let us see uh please go and put
down your questions in the Q a box here
so maybe let's start with the live
project demo questions we have gotten a
lot of them uh I can see one question uh
what is the difference between a
recommendation system and Association
rules sorry
I didn't get your question
uh I think we've got a question on the
project live project demo which you've
done what is the difference between a
recommendation system and Association
rules
Association rules rules
so a recommendation system is more
something like
built on Association techniques only
where we are basically trying to find
out
uh you know like relationship between
two different songs or two different
users based on that relationship
we
recommend uses something so
recommendation and Association rule
mining are somewhat similar it's just
that I suppose you can rule my name is
solely based on patent detection so
let's say if I'm buying if if I buy item
a
then I'm more likely to buy Item B and
this thing is done by basically you know
like using all the data about the and
the data about that item and other items
somethingwat similar to the coordination
system but
it just finds the association assembly
it did I align this item or not or did I
like the other item or not that's it
when we come to recommendation system it
is much more deeper and it uses on it it
is basically based on user Behavior and
also the item that I'm trying to buy and
other user Behavior which is missing in
an association tool binding
I hope I was clear about your question
yeah I hope that answers your question
and let us know in chat thank you so
much all for answering that uh we have
an interesting one by Supriya here what
do you recommend we should learn we
should do to learn how to start building
our own code in AIM
if you want I think the course itself is
something you should begin with to start
coding in here
and apart from it you can you can always
go and Learn Python and
then maybe try to find
websites like kaggle and
you know uh open AI or hugging face
where you can find different models and
try to use those models to build
something
well thank you so much for answering
that uh I hope that answers your
questions let us know and chat here and
I can see one question from Michael here
uh what motivates you when you're facing
a really hard problem and you can't get
over something over and over during many
days or when you just can't understand
the exact machine learning models or
techniques
first of all when I can't find the
solution to any problem
it makes me a little bit obsessive about
finding a solution about that problem at
times it's very you know like
important to take a break look take a
step back see what exactly MB language
what's the problem and then
see if your approach is right and apart
from it one thing which really works out
is talking to people who work with you
who are experts in domain
and who have done something which you
are trying to do if you talk to these
people if you go to these communities
which you can find on the internet you
can find a Discord or you can find on
a lot of other platforms talk to these
people see if they have faced something
similar and if they can recommend you
the path which will help you resolve
these things
because you may not be able to learn all
of all of the things out there and
same thing goes you know like
even the most brilliant my Engineers
they rely on other people to get some
solutions which they don't know about
thank you so much I hope that answers
your question I think we have gotten
very similar questions of how exactly
are data scientist is different from an
artificial intelligence engineer can you
tell us more about that and even roles
you know in data science and artificial
intelligence we have gotten a lot of
questions about that
yeah so like you know up to certain
level data science and AIML are kind of
related to each other they are very same
but at the same time at the end of the
day they are very different and how they
are different data science is like
basically let's say I mean in in
spotify's context if we put out we
talked about song we talked about genre
we talk about users now as a data
scientist you your job would be to you
know use that all of that data clean it
prepare it for analysis see what
attempts and insights are out there so
maybe you would get to know okay I think
in 2023 users are listening to a lot of
1966 1960s song it might be a trend you
know like maybe you can just use some
feature on Spotify we can put a playlist
of 1960s relived into 2023 and users May
user app a lot more so a data scientist
basically deals with business problems
recommends Solutions Based on data they
know about inside from there and
this is like a data scientist is more of
a business enabler you know like a guide
for business teams out there at the same
time if we talk about ai ai is more
towards building and coding stuff so you
may know a lot about models and you know
like systems out there and in machine
learning and AI space this as we
discussed about the terminal system but
when your company wants like let's say
your data scientist recommends your
company that if we put out when users
are ordering food from our website if
you put out other food which are similar
to that food or goes well with that
let's say if I if somebody is ordering
main course if you put out starters or
you know like they said as a
recommendation they are more likely to
buy that it's an inside which data
scientists might give based on the data
that they're seeing you know like based
on the orders pass orders and all of
that stuff now your company can't
recommend items you know like manually
like nobody would sit and recommend
items so now they need to build
something and that's where AIML
practitioners come into picture where
they will build a tool or equivalent
system which will take all the data and
passed into SLE board and start
recommending items based on what users
are ordering so they will start
recommending the desserts or main
portraits or what you have ordered
oh thank you so much sorry for answering
that I hope your answer answers your
question I think we have answered a lot
of questions here saurabh has already
replied to them uh you know in the Q a
box so that's great now uh moving on uh
basically if you need any assistance in
Android link to the program so you can
see a quick poll on your screen uh this
will help us understand if you need
assistance in enrolling to the program
so I would highly recommend to take the
help why not take the help you're
getting right so it's always good good
to take the extra help so uh so please
let us know if you need assistance in an
auditory program if you have chosen that
if you want to enroll into this program
and you have also voted how soon do you
plan to enroll as well so please let us
know if you need assistance in enrolling
through the program you can see a big
pool on the screen
thank you
so I can see most of the folks have
already voted in and uh I can see more
votes coming for the assistance part so
it's always good to take the help you
know uh when uh given so based on this
uh what we'll be teaching out to you and
uh basically without admissions offer
later and the civilians learning
consultant will be helping you out uh to
take you through a much detailed
walkthrough of the program as well if
you have any questions you can get your
questions clarified there as well so I
can see most of the folks have already
voted in but I'll give it 10 seconds
more uh before we close this phone
okay
think the folks who have not voted
please share us like if you need
assistance to enroll into the program
you can see the option yes here and also
know like let us know if you are a in
need of the assistance in enrolling to
them what use aim is a post-creative
program
awesome I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds I can see most of the folks have
already voted uh so five
four three two one
I'm closing the port thank you so much I
think most of the folks have taken the
option to actually take the assistance
and that's great so now uh we will be
ending the webinar here uh and thank you
so much all for joining us and taking us
through basically how you can build a
Spotify electric machine engine and uh I
can see if a few of the folks have
already responded on chat here that you
know a lot of appreciations coming in
for you so sort of thank you so much
thank you and good luck quotes for your
journey I like I really wish you build
something
interesting and mind doing like Spotify
as well
thank you thank you thank you so much
folks
being a great audience here uh